ein mädchen schreibt mädchen wollen
heutzutage nur das eine
das führt jetzt 3 2 sg willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute mit marilyn
monroe ist alles klar wollten wir zum
beispiel bei den komplett gut oder
scheiße kraft und hat schon viel gesehen
leute wir reden heute über vorurteile
von jungs und mädchen kann ich natürlich
nur machen wenn ich auch qualifiziert
das mädchen quasi nebenher oder dann
wird wieder so machen vorurteile über
mädels mit seiner bewährten vorteile
über jungs wertig bewerten wir klären
die wir erst mal auf der braker schreibt
jungs müssen immer den ersten schritt
machen class okay dann sag ich jetzt mal
was dazu ich finde nämlich ich habe so
ein bisschen wahrgenommen dass ich habe
viele mädels ist eigentlich schon so ist
ja ich glaube für einige ist es echt
schon so es gibt auch ein paar habe ich
auch selbst schon erlebt dass auch
mädels einfach auf mich zugekommen sind
und das quasi von sich aus zu gestartet
haben was ich auch gar nicht schlecht
finde weil dies megawatt ich finde es
nicht schlimm weil ich persönlich besser
als andere jungs für sie den ersten
schritt machen
ich finde es echt cool ich will dass
kuba das zeug auch bisschen davon dass
man so ein bisschen aus sich rauskommen
kann bei mir ist's halt die sache ich
hasse es leute anzusprechen mit diesen
ersten moment so aufzubauen dass ich
hasse das ich finde viel geld im juni so
leute schon mit meiner freundin wir
freuen uns endlich ihr so kennenlerne
so jemand dann hört ja was sagst du dazu
ist aber auch dass ich glaube dass das
immer noch so an den köpfen drin ist das
ist eigentlich sein muss aber ich glaube
es gibt auch einige die ich finden
heutzutage kann man das ähnlich man
zusagen ansprechen weil es dafür viele
online ich damit die medien und die dann
vielleicht zuerst folgen
wer sich selbst ein bisschen so die
erfahrung gemacht dass ich einfach so
oft vermeintliche zeichen so überhaupt
nicht lesen kann also was für mädels
weltwunder eindeutig ist nicht irgendein
abrede
damals ist halt so wir haben uns zu ganz
kurz getroffen und ist nach hause
gegangen danach hat der halt nicht mehr
geschrieben aber ich habe auch nicht
geschrieben
ich dachte ich so dass er mich ankotzt
aber der hat erzählt dass ich ihn
gekauft
das war so werden wenn er mir hat keiner
von uns sind die signale gezeigt ich
könnte das genau ich glaube so was hatte
ich genau schon mal mit so mäder von
meiner uni auch schon mal getroffen ich
ganz cool und danach hat er keine wir
sind wir denn eigentlich geschrieben wir
beide denken wir statt ich bis jetzt
hassen aber ich weiß nicht ob es niemals
auf den namen nein kommt niemals darauf
dass ein geräusch ist
ich finde ein komplettes red ihrem ex
crime schreibt mädchen schminken sich
nur für jungs was sagst du dazu
klar wenn man so irgendwie auf jeden
fall den partner abbekommen hat jetzt
einen tipp oder eine frau und dann will
man sich auch auf topfen aber ich glaube
in erster linie schmeckt man sich halt
um sich selber bringen wie zu verwandeln
so also bisschen so mehr als sich eine
frau aus deutschland für uns ist das
schon also wären so drauf ist der kein
klatschen
wenn leute denken es war auch schon
kraft weil das heißt ja eigentlich dass
mädels nur da wären und für jungs sind
was ihr kompletter bullshit ist ja so
dass nämlich das problem ist irgendwo um
die männer glücklich denn ich glaube es
hat wie bei allen menschen so aber wird
sich das viertel klamotten kaufen oder
sich herausputzt ist es auch natürlich
auch ein bisschen für andere wenn man so
will das andere als cool wahrnehmen das
macht ja auch also wenn du dich selber
willst dann hast du auch eine bessere
ausstrahlung so eine mischung aus für
sich selbst für anderen es gibt leute
die sagen dass ich solche wahrheiten
nicht richtig schlimm aus sondern
richtig maximieren deutlich bestätigen
richtig gut doch doppel aber nächstes
vorteil kommen von ed leid sondern die
schreiben mädchen geht immer zu zweit
aufs klo
also vielleicht einfach dabei sein
privaten raum hat uns über alles
sprechen kann
ich glaube ich dass die nur zu zweit
oder auch umso strategien zu besprechen
so eine geschichte mitverfolgen so eine
gruppe von mädels getroffen in berlin
dann so klar waren die messen wir auch
mal zusammen auch vielleicht oder so und
dann danach irgendwann hatten die mir
deine mir erzählt dass sie kann sich von
anfang an so mit ihren freundinnen
abgesprochen hatte wer jetzt mit welchen
tag aus der gruppe
geht ja auch nur wenn diese
zwischenzeitlich woanders waren ist es
auch so ein ding das man so strategien
bespricht wenn wir zurückkommen das zu
dritt auf den drauf springen uns eine
workload pixel kredite schreibt jungs
trainieren damit muskeln mädels
imponieren zu können
die sache ist da dass auch ein paar
darum geht dass man sich selbst so mit
seinem eigenen körper wohlfühlt
gewissermaßen ist ja schon ein bisschen
drucker auf einer mit dem gewissen
schönheitsideal zu entsprechen
bei männern ist es halt einfach auch wir
frauen auch ein trainierter körper muss
gelöst
das höre ich aber auch von vielen mädels
so wenn ihr nicht so trainiert seit oder
einfach keinen bock hat auch spannend
ist klar wichtig dafür viel auf den kopf
und so glaube ich einfach ein bisschen
sport zu machen als ausgleich aber ich
finde es ist öffentlich
wenn ihr in der klasse feld oder so was
so krampfhaft wichtig jetzt findest du
machen dann schickte aber klar machen
also eines mega wichtig dass er in
klassen bizeps hat so krass wie meiner
ist halt für jeden unterschiedlich was
also mehr wichtig ist sein wichtigstes
eigenen körpers trainiert oder so ist
auch für einen selbst zum beispiel ich
habe oder wie eine störung in der
hinsicht so ich bin so vor der nazis ich
habe mich gerne im spiegel nicht so dass
ich mich so einfach nur zu sagen so
katja gey liste aufgenommen wenn ich mir
also schaufenster vorbei doch dann
schockierte wenn ich aber eigentlich
auch immer vielleicht sollte man auch
nicht offen darüber reden
das hat folgen die rechtliche seite
[Musik]
ein mädchen schreibt mädchen wollen
heutzutage nur das eine
es wird jetzt aber erst mal schauen wie
man sieht also dass halt mir dass wir
sex mit verschiedenen produkten es gibt
schon welche also ich habe auch ein
bisschen einfacher fast dran wird
irgendwelche warum also wird verdächtigt
es wird nicht so viel hier aber keine
ahnung ich halt etwas leichter bisher in
welche richtung inhalt übertreibt dann
werden bestimmt noch viel mehr mit ihren
werden und uneheliche kinder zeigen und
dann mit 14 schwanger ja verschlafen wir
das halt sofort trend ist dass jeder so
was mit jedem hat gut ich finde es an
sich nicht so dramatisch weil ich meine
so dem sinne dass mädels selbst
entscheiden können verlage und auch
sogenannte ich hasse es manche dieses
der mädchen uns schlimmer jungs nicht so
das ist echt geil veraltet und ich aber
ich finde generell ab mein typ ist oder
eine frau sollte man schon ein bisschen
dass man jetzt vielleicht
nicht übertreibt also du denkst du an
die gesundheit der menschheit würde ich
auch sagt dass in diesem sinne von
unserem ersten gemeinsamen video
zusammen soll ich eine beschreibung
verlinkt checkt sie abonniert sie und
das display auf videobildern persönlich
mit chorgesang ist wie bekommen jemand
klar abonnieren und schreibt man in die
kommentare damit es nicht so schlecht
wie schön natürlich